bonjour voila on vous retrouve la
liaison est maintenant avec vous ce
confinement est ce que vous vous y
attendiez en belgique
est ce que c'est un soulagement pour le
corps médical on s'y attendait un peu
'l'annonce déjà depuis quelque temps est
ce que c'est un soulagement
je vous dirais pas que c'est un
soulagement dans le sens où c'est un
petit peu un peu pas excessif mais c'est
un petit peu difficile à supporter du
point de vue humain comme citoyen en
tout cas c'est je pense que le problème
vient plus du non respect des mesures
qui étaient déjà en application que de
ces nouvelles mesures qui pourraient ne
rien changer à la situation en fait
comment les belges perçoivent ce nouveau
confinement est ce qu'ils sont dans le
même état d'esprit que vous je pense que
la population en a vraiment ras le bol
je pense que beaucoup de voix se sont
élevées pour exiger demandé que les
écoles restent ouvertes et on a observé
quand même il y avait un problème dans
l'application et le respect des mesures
qui étaient déjà d'application jusque là
voilà ceci étant dit la pente
d'augmentation des nombre
d'hospitalisations en soins intensifs et
dans les hôpitaux les certes en
progression mais elle aime beaucoup
moins brutale que lors de la première et
de la deuxième vague
ça veut dire que les choses étaient plus
ou moins contenue et je peux imaginer
que le gouvernement a voulu resserrer la
vis moi je pense qu'il aurait mieux valu
insisté et assurer un bon suivi des
mesures qui étaient déjà en application
que d'en rajouter une en plus vu que les
personnes qui ne respectaient déjà pas
les règles ne vont peut-être pas les
respecter
face à ce serrage de vis
et la situation actuelle dans les
hôpitaux à la situation allait sous
contrôle
donc nous avons déjà on a un plan
d'action avec différentes phases
d'activation du nombre de deux lits
qu'il faut mettre à disposition pour les
patients qu'aux vide
nous sommes aujourd'hui à peu près à 3 %
d'occupation des lits de soins intensifs
nous sommes en phase 1b qui pourrait
passer bientôt en phase ii à ce qu'on
attendait comme corps médical en fait du
gouvernement c'est une accélération
massive des vaccinations et cela n'a pas
été le cas parce que la vaccination en
belgique dépend des régions et donc les
régions sont plus ou moins coordonnée
par le fédéral qui fournit les vaccins
mais chaque région doit établir un petit
peu son plan d'action et et sa
logistique propre
il y a eu quand même énormément de
cafouillage je pense qu'il n'est pas
acceptable
après bientôt trois mois d'arrivée du
vaccin dans le pays d'en être à un petit
7 % de vaccination de la population
on peut se réjouir que ce sont les
personnes les plus fragiles qui ont été
vaccinés et tous les soignants
ça va peut-être faciliter la gestion de
cette troisième valent mais vraiment
j'attendais beaucoup plus que ça comme
nombre de vaccins et de vaccination de
la population
pointé le problème des doses et les
retards de livraison peut-être c'est un
peu le cas aussi dans de nombreux pays
c'est le cas chez nous en france dans
d'autres pays européens comme
l'allemagne et la belgique comment vous
l'expliquez comment vous expliquer cette
situation la faute à qui c'est un
problème logistique 1 je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de scientifiques qui font
partie d'énormément de comités d'experts
beaucoup de virologues épidémiologistes
qui travaille essentiellement dans l'est
dans des laboratoires nous avons des
politiques qui doivent essayer de
trouver un consensus entre deux des
valeurs qu'ils ont toutes la même
importance donc des valeurs sanitaires
mais aussi des valeurs de liberté et de
droit je dirais de bouger de circuler et
donc c'est ça c'est le rôle du politique
est donc ce que je ne vois pas beaucoup
ce sont des personnes qui sont
relativement bien bien
concernés et bien adepte des pratiques
de la halle de l'organisation et de la
logistique
vous savez étaient rationnés actuelle il
ya un sommet virtuel des 27
aujourd'hui scoci vous pointez la
gestion européenne en matière justement
de vaccination bien sûr on est on est
vraiment bien loin de l'efficacité d'un
pays comme israël est donc aujourd'hui
l'europe est là certes commander les
vaccins mais on a aussi entendu en
belgique que des doses qui était prévu
pour la belgique ont été achetés par
d'autres pays donc que ce n'est pas du
tout compréhensible pour la population
on apprend qu énormément de consultants
sont venus prêter main forte aux
organisateurs et aux régions et le
résultat il est vraiment loin d'être
acceptable
les médecins en belgique que je
représente ne sont toujours pas
autorisées en dehors des hôpitaux à
pouvoir vacciner les patients les
médecins généralistes sont demandeurs de
pouvoir participer à cette vaccination
mais ils n'ont toujours pas cette
autorisation
donc quand même énormément de problèmes
de point de vue organisationnel qui
retarde la vaccination et ceci n'est
absolument pas acceptable pour la
population et s'agit sonder la
circulation des variants aux quelles
sont vos observations telle est la
situation en belgique un ace qui elle le
varia anglais circule activement par
exemple oui le variant du circulent mais
on s'attendait à ce que le virus mute
comme tous les virus et celui là dès le
début muté énormément donc tôt ou tard
on allait avoir des mutations qui allait
amener des variants un peu plus agressif
c'est le cas on sait maintenant que je
dirais les vaccins agissent peut-être
pas tout aussi bien vis-à-vis des
variants que les avis de la souche de
base mais ils sont quand même très
efficace et donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment continuer à vacciner
c'est là c'est la seule la seule issue
en fait un on ne peut pas confiné une
population éternellement sous prétexte
que c'est difficile de faire autrement
donc moi je un appel je lance un appel
aux autorités européennes et des pays
concernés de mettre en place toutes les
mesures qu'il faut kita à mettre
l'argent qu'il faut pour qu'ils aient
une vaccination de la population de
façon massive et rapide
merci beaucoup avoue gilbert bejan et je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste président de l'association
belge des syndicats médicaux